all right it is so lovely to meet you
too you guys are coordinated wasn't
planned no no it's just this is the
first time we're seeing you guys back
together since interstellar such a great
film this this movie what would you say
was the biggest difference this time
around working together my costumes were
a lot more comfortable I don't want to
like moan or anything but the space suit
was so hung come
I remember thinking ok you're the only
girl on this you know glacier you can't
complain about how heavy this costume is
you can't do it you just can't you got
to toughen up hathaway toughen up and
then on his first day about 20 minutes
in Matt Damon just pitched forward and
this is the worst costume I've ever worn
ok good so um but I was just so happy I
was just so happy to not start and
square one with you and just kind of
know that every place that we were gonna
get to go it was going to be intense and
deep and youthful and high-quality and
then I was going to be safe I just knew
that so I was a really excited I like
that what about you it was different I
mean the roles are obviously very very
different but I new word used for
earlier this is very good with her
values when it comes to what our craft
is and then what acting is and we have
similar work ethic and values when it
comes to that so I knew I was in a place
where like oh good I trust this I'm
again working with a heavyweight I'm
gonna she's gonna challenge me in good
ways and we're gonna our initial
conversations are already gonna be quite
evolved when it comes to talking about
scenes in relationship because we both
gone and done our work beforehand and
that's part of the pleasure one of the
pleasures of working with and for me so
the boat is called serenity but the
circumstances surrounding your
characters are anything but serene so
what a play game is kind of a joke in it
so I wanted to play a game serenity or
anxiety you tell me which one would it
be for you okay so being on a boat in
the middle of the ocean is that serenity
or anxiety
I mean it depends on the weather but
serenity yet it's more serene you okay
unless you're unless you're seasick that
sucks
oh that's that's anxiety left alone with
your kids for the entire weekend and I
mean alone alone left alone with the
kids for an entire weekend that's got
some anxiety to it yeah promise yeah
yeah that's just exhaustion that's just
hard okay both moments moments of
serenity where you're like I got this
and then a few seconds later you're like
oh it's yeah I got three okay crap you
got to go I know if I can just get the
third one on this all three of them are
going I'll do the same thing yeah okay I
don't want to say watch you can watch
that TV show cuz that does my work for
me but boy I'm getting close to saying
that my friends is this great phrase he
says don't try to make a happy kid
happier yeah like don't wake a sleeping
baby yeah well thank you guys so
serenity or anxiety hosting the Oscars
anxiety take trust me was the doing of
it anxiety no because I was in such a
place of denial that I was convinced for
having a wonderful telling it so so it
was but um but I wasn't telling the
truth I was just so deep inside to
survival survived survival but no but it
was it was at the aftermath of it was
anxious for a long time
you